[Musik]
und zerstören wieder schöne Rüben für
flüssiggasterminal spannende Themen
spannende Gäste die bekannteste Link in
unserem Land Sahra Wagenknecht waren vor
dem
heizungs-publizist Henrik ein Bruder wie
Sie sehen frisch vom Strand eingeflogen
wundert sich Verzicht auf eigenen Kinder
für das Klima das seid ihr Sinn er
selbst ist ja auch gerade wieder Opa
geworden und sehr glücklich deswegen
wird das hier gefeiert Filly Gitarrist
und osticone Uwe Hass Becker lebt selbst
auf Rügen und waren vor dem Bau der LMG
Terminals das zerstöre die Ostsee NZZ
Journalisten so seine Gaschke knüpft
sich heute Deutschlands größten TV
Philosophen Richard David Precht vor
seine Kritik an Außenminister falsch und
mein Top Thema des Tages ist
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Harbeck denn
der sorgt für ein Wirtschaftswunder aber
leider nicht bei uns ähm immer mehr
Großkonzerne wie VW BASF verlegen ihre
Produktion ins Ausland jetzt sorgt auch
der Verkauf des Familienunternehmen zu
Wissmann an einem amerikanischen
Klimaanlagen Herr dafür Entsetzen für 12
Milliarden geht die wärmepumpenspatel in
us-konsent careal global und da würde
ich direkt gerne Frau Wagenknecht fragen
was ist da los und wird Deutschland die
industrialisiert also die Gefahr ist
zumindest sehr groß und mit jeder
spinnerten Idee die habe ich unter die
Leute bringen will wächst die Gefahr
dass Deutschland in zehn Jahren nicht
mehr zu den führenden Industrieländern
gehört und da kommen ja viele Dinge
zusammen natürlich hat das schon vor der
von der unter der letzten Regierung
begonnen das betrifft ja auch die
Bildungspolitik viele andere Fragen aber
was wir jetzt erleben mit den extremen
Energiepreisen mit den Regeln die jetzt
geschaffen werden mit einem völligen
Verzicht auf eine irgendwie konsistente
Industriepolitik was wir bräuchten also
ich meine andere Länder machen das
völlig skrupellos der Markt alleine
richtet dass eben nicht die USA macht
ein riesiges Investitionsprogramm womit
sie
Zukunftstechnologien in die USA holt und
die dort subventioniert die Chinesen
machen das sowieso also ich meine dort
ist das so sehr stark vom Staat auch
gesteuerte und subventionierte
Wirtschaft aber sie schaffen es
geschickt auch Zukunftstechnologien aus
Deutschland die wir entwickelt haben zu
sich zu holen und in die Massenfertigung
zu nehmen und wir sind immer mehr blanke
und ich finde wir müssen da wirklich
aufpassen also wenn uns das passiert was
andere Länder in Europa schon erlebt
haben Italien Großbritannien
großflächige die Industrialisierung dann
ist unser Wohlstand weg und ich halte
diese Regierung wirklich für so
inkompetent und für so gefährlich was
unsere industrielle Substanz angeht dass
ich finde das muss man das muss man
blockieren das darfst du nicht
weitergehen Bruder teilen Sie die Angst
vor dem Industrialisierung ja erstmal
möchte ich sagen himmlisches Risiko
eingehe mit Frau Wagen nicht an einem
Tisch zu sitzen das könnte da als
Kontakt Schuld ausgelegt werden
und ich frage mich auch ob es
Konsequenzen haben wenn ich in den
zustimme ich fürchte sie haben
vollkommen recht nur in einem Punkt sind
sie zu optimistisch es wird nicht zehn
Jahre dauern das wird schneller gehen
Deutschland wird der industrialisiert
zugleich gibt es eine
allgemeine Reform des Soziallebens in
der Bundesrepublik es gibt wieder
Ausgrenzungen es gibt wieder
subventioniertesten und sie habentum es
gibt eine Übergriffigkeit des Staates
wie es sich hier seit 45 nicht gegeben
hat nicht mal unter Adenauer haben sie
ein Beispiel für die Übergriffigkeit des
Staates ja zum Beispiel es gibt ein
riesen Programm beim Familienministerium
glaube ich das heißt Demokratie leben
und soweit ich weiß es Deutschland das
einzige demokratische Land das seinen
Bürgern Demokratie beibringt
normalerweise ist eigentlich genau
umgekehrt die Bürger Lehren die
Regierung Demokratie gelegentlich durch
eine Abfall es gibt ein riesiges System
das inzwischen mehrere Milliarden kostet
destoventionierung von NGOs und anderen
Gesellschaften die eigentlich
Vorfeldorganisation der Regierung sind
wir haben 45 anders beauftragte und ich
glaube eine ähnliche Zahl von
Staatssekretären dieses Land ist zu
einer Art
selbstbedienungsfabrik geworden weil die
unfähigsten Leute in staatssekretäres
und anderer Posten berufen werden die
vorher bei
Umweltorganisationen oder Firmen die für
die Umwelt gearbeitet haben führende
Position hatten sie können zwischen
Lobbyismus und
offizieller ministerarbeit beinahe hätte
ich gesagt Ministrantenarbeit können sie
nicht mehr unterscheiden also ich weiß
nicht ob die Wirtschaft jetzt durch
Demokratie leben unbedingt außer
landesgedrängt wird auch wenn ich das
ein sehr kritisches ein sehr
kritikwürdiges Programm findet also das
ist sozusagen die mit 200 Millionen oder
212 Millionen glaube ich Euro im Jahr
inzwischen ist das mehr als die gesamten
demokratischen Parteien in Deutschland
an Parteien Finanzierung bekommen also
man schafft sich da eine völlig
undurchsichtige Parallelstruktur das
wird die Unternehmen wahrscheinlich
relativ kalt lassen was sie nicht kalt
lassen wird ist was da jetzt geplant
wird nämlich z.B ein Verbandsklage recht
für diskriminierungsfragen also dann
geht jemand selbst hin zum Arbeitgeber
was ich ja immer schwer ist und
beschwert sich aber er könnte auch in
der Gewerkschaft eintreten sich
organisieren und sich wehren gegenüber
Griffe jetzt kann er also zu einem
Sozialverband gehen und der also wenn
das wenn das so kommt diese Gesetzgebung
klagt so das sehen die
Unternehmerverbände meines Wissen sehr
kritisch und ich glaube das ist ein
zentraler Punkt wir schreiben vor in
Deutschland also wir lassen gar keinen
Raum für Eigeninitiative ich glaube das
was in Amerika jetzt so erfolgreich ist
ist tatsächlich dass man alle Anreize
setzt also dass man sagt macht es wie
ihr wollt aber erreicht halt die Ziele
das ist sozusagen einer einer freien
Gesellschaft glaube ich durchaus viel
würdiger ich beobachte allerdings auch
dass die grüne Rhetorik bei den
Deutschen Wirtschaftsverbänden auch
schon gut angekommen ist also zum guten
Ton gehört es dass man sich erstens bis
zehntens jetzt wirklich mal als Klima
Kämpfer bekehrt aber Frau apropos grün
ähm kann es nicht doch auch durchaus
sein ich meine der Wirtschaftsminister
habe ich ist ja ein grüner und die
Grünen mögen ja eigentlich
wirtschaftliche schrumpfen aus einem
Grund weil dann das Klima besser da
steht die Meinung haben ja schon manche
grüne die entsprechen ich könnte es
nicht auch sein dass Herr Habeck da ein
Interessenskonflikt hat also ich kann
mir das nicht ernsthaft vorstellen da
ich Ihnen als klugen Mann kenne
sozusagen der auch weiß dass diese diese
Volkswirtschaft ja irgendwie weiter
funktionieren muss und das ja so
irgendwo das Geld herkommen muss für die
ganzen schönen Förderprogramme für die
NGOs und für die es gibt Sondervermögen
es gibt das Schuldnervermögen das Geld
kommt immer von irgendwoher und der
Staat hat nicht das geringste Problem
auf eine ziemlich artifizielle Weise
Geld herzlich aber wir wissen ja beide
oder wir finden das ja beide ganz falsch
und gefährlich also für für die die
Spirale für die Inflation
funktioniert
in Ordnung ja nur irgendwann wird es den
Leuten ja auch bewusst also die die
Industrialisierung in Großbritannien
hatte glaube ich dann noch mal wieder
ganz andere Gründe als sie jetzt hier
möglicherweise hat und eine ganz andere
Richtung gegangen aber sie hat natürlich
für die Bevölkerung entsprechende Folgen
gehabt eben sobald das hier zu spüren
ist haben wir auch andere Mehrheiten ja
erstmal sind die ja gewählt und man muss
natürlich schon aufpassen also in
wirtschaftlichen Prozessen ist ja immer
das Problem man kann sie nicht einfach
zurückdrehen also es gibt einfach eine
bestimmte Dynamik die kann man bis zu
einem bestimmten Punkt stoppen aber wenn
sie dann über dieses Stadium hinaus ist
dann kommt es nicht wieder also
Unternehmen die jetzt abwandern die
würden auch wenn die nächste
Bundesregierung versucht andere Weichen
zu stellen nicht direkt zurückkommen
sondern das ist ja eine grundsätzliche
Investitionsentscheidung gehe ich jetzt
in die USA gehe ich woanders hin wenn
das einmal getroffen ist dann ist es so
und wir haben das ja immer wieder erlebt
ich meine so ganz neu ist es auch nicht
ist ein bisschen ungerecht sozusagen die
die Grünen sind schuld wenn man die
Union war zu ihrer Zeit nicht viel
besser die SPD hat ja auch die ganze
Zeit regiert ich meine Deutschland hat
immer wieder wirklich
innovative technologisch gute Lösungen
entwickelt hier im Land deswegen bei den
Batterien an das war bei den
solarpanellen so das ist bei anderen
Innovationen so und wir schaffen es
nicht weil die Politik einfach nicht
drauf achtet oder ihr das egal ist oder
weil sie eben wirklich auch diesen
Glauben hat das muss von selbst
passieren wir schaffen es nicht das
System automatisch im Land zu halten und
hier Innovation wirklich permanent zu
fördern weil ich meine diese ganze
klimaideologie ich meine ich will auch
dass der Klimawandel gestoppt wird ich
will dass wir unsere natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen bewahren aber genauso
ist doch klar dass wir das nicht dadurch
erreichen dass wir das ganze Land voll
Windräder stellen und dass wir überall
so nach Solarpaneele aufstellen sondern
es ist klar wir brauchen neue
Technologien wir brauchen innovative
Lösungen also müsste der Staat gemeinsam
mit Unternehmen die USA macht das eben
so mit Förderprogrammen versuchen
Innovation zu fördern aber sie dann auch
im Land zu halten und wenn mir wirklich
auch wieder Innovationen made in Germany
entsteht kann die ja dann auch auf dem
Weltmarkt erfolgreich sein aber sie muss
erstmal hier im Lande entstehen und sie
muss dann auch hier im Lande quasi zur
Massenproduktion kommen und nicht in
China und da gibt es einfach kein
Verständnis dafür sondern das lässt man
laufen und ich meine jetzt man nennt es
ja immer hinten Champion ist ein
Mittelständler die wirklich weltweit
eigentlich mit innovativen Lösungen
bestehen Deutschland
Champions in Deutschland hatte da ganz
viele ja aber es werden immer weniger
und sie haben es wird ihnen das Leben
eher schwer gemacht als dass man sie
fördert und das ist eine idiotische
Politik aber liegt es nicht daran dass
an so vielen Stellen Ideologie wirklich
tatsächlich zum Tragen kommt also nicht
zu sagen wir wir machen sozusagen
ergebnisoffene Förderprogramme oder
technologieoffene Förderprogramme
erreicht die Ziele so wo ist die
Forschungsinitiative also die die
regulieren wir gerade zu Tode mit einem
super unattraktiven Arbeitsbedingungen
für junge Forscher die dann also
sozusagen gar kein Interesse haben da
weiter zu machen aber das ist einfach
der Kern also dass wir nicht sagen wir
brauchen technologieoffene Innovation
wir sind noch nicht so weit also ich
meine manchmal kommt mir das vor so wie
so ein Kind das dann aufstand und sagen
wir wollen jetzt CO2 neutral sein und
deswegen machen wir plötzlich machen
irgendwelche Schnellschüsse
irgendwelchen Aktionismus der blind ist
der der überhaupt nichts nützt statt zu
verstehen wir brauchen da noch neue
Technologien es gibt genügend Forschung
aber wir müssen sie weiter fördern da
muss man Geld investieren und nicht in
solche Projekte wie sie habe ich jetzt
vorantreibt wo einzelne Ideologien
wahrscheinlich weil der entsprechende
Lobbyist gerade das Ohr des
Wirtschaftsministers erreicht hat
einzelne einzelne Technologien massiv
gefördert werden die am Ende wenn man
sie im Gesamt betrachte gar nicht also
weder dem Klima noch sonst
nicht fähig nur ein Wort was sie sagen
ich stimme zu aber ich höre das seit 15
20 Jahren wird das Land kommt nicht mal
bei der Digitalisierung voran schauen
sich die ewigen Schulreformen ist auch
die fragen sich die Rechtschreibreform
an also banale Sachen Herbert achten
muss was glaube ich an den deutschen
Zustand als rasenden Stillstand
bezeichnet vielleicht was auch jemand
anders
deswegen als erstes vorhin auch Bildung
also wenn wir über die
industrieindustrialisierung reden müssen
wir über das deutsche Bildungssystem
reden weil seit 64
Bildungssystem reden würde ich gerne
einmal hören
wiederholt und natürlich fragen ob er
sich denn eigentlich von der Politik gut
repräsentiert fühlt ich finde dass die
deutsche Bundesregierung ziemlich da
arbeitet sehr unflexibel ist und
sozusagen auf aktuelle Geschehnisse und
nicht in der Lage ist auf aktuelle
Veränderungen der Geschehnisse
einzugehen und sozusagen es kommt mir
ein bisschen vor im Osten gab es den
sogenannten Fünfjahresplan
das wird einfach durchgezogen was man
sich irgendwann vorgenommen ohne
sozusagen auf aktuelle tatsächliche
gravierende Veränderungen eingehen zu
können ja und das sind hier schon eine
Parallele zum Fünfjahresplan glauben Sie
nicht das ist vielleicht etwas
nehme ich mir einfach mal raus und ähm
ja also es gehört sozusagen es ist
einfach jeder Betrieb der sozusagen
privatschaftlich arbeitet ist doch
gezwungen sozusagen zu reagieren auf auf
Veränderung und klug zu reagieren und
das ist alles so stark die hat da gibt's
irgendeine Direktive die Wärmepumpe mehr
von mir dabei ein das ist äh das ist
krank was da passiert und vor allem die
kommen in die Kommunikation ist quasi
überhaupt nicht vorhanden man muss doch
die Leute mitnehmen wenn man sie von
irgendwas überzeugen möchte ja und die
nehmen die Leute nicht mit er sein
exzellente Übergang nicht
ja also wir haben ja jetzt ein ganz
großes klimaprojekt angeblich von Herrn
Habig überall sollen jetzt die Gas und
Ölheizungen raus und die neue
Zukunftstechnologie ist die Wärmepumpe
wenn man mit irgendeinem Experten der
sich ein bisschen den Bereich auskennt
redet dann erfährt man überall das
Gleiche wärmepumpen sind sicher eine
sinnvolle Technologie für moderne
Niedrigenergiehäuser überhaupt keine
Frage für alte
ältere weniger gedämmte Gebäude mit
älteren Heizungsanlagen sind Wärmepumpen
einfach völlig ineffizient man kriegt
das Haus nicht warm die Energiekosten
explodieren das heißt man muss nicht nur
die teure Wärmepumpe einbauen man muss
eigentlich sein ganzes Haus umbauen man
muss dämmen man muss die Heizung umbauen
und da sind reden wir über Kosten in die
Richtung von mehreren 100.000 € ganz
schnell und die haben nur die wenigsten
Bürger im sparstrom und da finde ich ist
die Regierung auch einfach unehrlich sie
behauptet ja niemand wird sein Haus
verlieren niemand wird nicht mehr heizen
können aber dann kommt Herr Lauterbach
um die Ecke und sagt na ja aber wir
müssen Ausnahmen machen nämlich
Ausnahmen für Pflegeheime und
Krankenhäuser damit die nicht in ihrer
Existenz bedroht werden müssen muss es
so sein dass bei Pflegeheimen und
Krankenhäusern also dass die nicht ihre
Gas und Ölheizung verschrotten müssen
weil sonst wären sie in ihrer Existenz
bedroht nun stimme ich ja hier
ausnahmsweise Lauterbach in dem Sinne zu
dass ich auch nicht will das
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheim in der
Existenz bedroht werden aber normale
Familien oder
ältere Rentner die jetzt gerade ihren
Ruhestand in ihrem abbezahlten Häuschen
genießen wollen die sollte man
bitteschön auch nicht in ihre Existenz
bedrohen ein völlig undurchdachtes
Projekt und vor allem der Clou ist es
bringt auch dem Klima nichts weil womit
werden die Wärmepumpen betrieben sie
werden mit Strom betrieben woher kommt
der Strom in Deutschland im Winter oft
zu über 80% aus fossilen Energieträgern
weil Solarstrom gibt's im Winter kaum
und wenn der Wind nicht bläst dann haben
wir eben vor allem wir haben die
Gaskraftwerke und wir haben die
Kohlekraftwerke das heißt die angeblich
sauberen wär warum werden mit fossilem
Strom betrieben und man hat das ja sogar
akzeptiert dass man dafür mehr Strom
braucht deswegen hat Habeck mehr
Gaskraftwerke schon genehmigt und um
diese Gaskraftwerke dann mit Gas
beliefern zu können bauen wir also jetzt
bis zu zwölf lng-terminals in die Ost-
und in die Nordsee LNG Terminals wo der
grüne Minister eine Sondererlaubnis
erteilt hat dass die tonnenweise Chlor
und andere giftige Abwässer in die
Nordsee und in die Ostsee entsorgen
dürfen das ist also grüne Politik das
soll eine Politik sein die unser Umwelt
erhält und noch ein Beispiel für völlig
inkonsistente Maßnahmen habe ich will ja
auch Solar Energie ausbauen was ja
erstmal erfreulich ist aber da frage ich
mich wieso quält man Hausbesitzer mit
einem riesigen bürokratischen Aufwand
wenn die auf ihr Dach eine Solaranlage
setzen wollen wieso macht man das
besonders unattraktiv weil wenn der
Strom dann ins Netz geht kriegt man
wenig Geld wenn man den Strom vom Netz
braucht muss man viel Geld bezahlen in
anderen Ländern ist das völlig anders da
sind Solarpaneele auf dem Dach so dass
der Stromzähler rückwärts läuft also
attraktiv nein habe ich will die Hälfte
der Solarpaneele auf Freiflächen setzen
also auf Wiesen auf Ecker was heißt den
Landwirten den Bauern wird das Leben
noch schwerer gemacht weil die
Bodenpreise hochgezogen werden wie Flora
und Fauna und die Tiere dort darauf
reagieren weil es sowieso gar keiner
wenn alles also jetzt zugepflastert wird
mit metallischen Solarpanelen und das
soll so grüne Politik sein also alles
das sind Maßnahmen die nicht
zusammenpassen das ist ökoaktivismus
völlig blind völlig undurchdacht und ich
finde so eine Politik können wir uns
nicht leisten ich will auch dass wir
unsere natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
halten ich will auch dass wir in Zukunft
anders heizen auch unseren Strom anders
erzeugen aber bitte schön dafür brauchen
wir innovative Technologien dafür
brauchen wir Ideen aber nicht solchen
Irrsinn wie ein habe ich betreibt der
ist ruinös für Millionen Menschen und er
bringt weder dem Klima noch dem noch der
Umwelt irgendeinen gewinnen das wäre
außer die Technologie denn eine Idee
ja also zum Beispiel beim Heizen kann
man in anderen Ländern sehen dass zum
Beispiel Dänemark in Dänemark sind über
60 Prozent aller Wohnungen und Häuser
entfernen Wärme angeschlossen und diese
Fernwärme wird tatsächlich überwiegend
mit erneuerbaren Energien betrieben mit
Biomasse zum Beispiel oder in Kopenhagen
haben sie ein System dass sie die Wärme
aus den Abwassern nutzen und damit diese
Heizung betreiben also es gibt schon
innovative Ideen wie man sowas machen
kann dafür braucht man Investitionen das
ist etwas was man wirklich dann auch
ganzheitlich durchdenken muss aber das
wäre doch ein Plan und nicht dieser
Irrsinn die Leute sollen ihre Gas und
Ölheizung verschrotten und sollen was
einbauen was einfach nicht funktioniert
und wie gesagt mit den solarpanellen ich
finde das auch eine gute Idee dass die
wenn der wenn der Stromzähler rückwärts
läuft wenn einer seine seine Solaranlage
wenn er da reinspeist und wenn er dann
Strom braucht dann kann er ihn sozusagen
zum gleichen Preis deaktiv wieder haben
würde für die Leute das attraktiv machen
würden viele wahrscheinlich aufs Dach
draufsetzen und dann finde ich muss man
eben wirklich meine
Technologien die halt noch nicht da sind
Fusionsreaktor oder ähnliche Dinge die
werden ja erforscht gibt Unternehmen die
daran arbeiten aber da ist ja immer
wieder so das ist langfristig privates
Kapital ist sehr zurückhaltend solche
langfristigen Dinge zu finanzieren weil
es ja unsicher ist also ist es sinnvoll
wenn der Staat das macht und das
unterstützt und das machen wir in
Deutschland viel zu wenig da ist die USA
tatsächlich besser in solchen fliegen
schauen einmal ob Herr Bruder ihn
vielleicht heute Abend schon wieder
zustimmen muss oder nicht ja ich möchte
ja das tut mir richtig weh aber es ist
so aber mein Bruder bin ich doch nicht
zustimmen darf nein nein außer ihrer
Position zu Putin würde ich in vielen
Punkten mit ihnen übereinstimmen dann
das trennt uns leider schauen Sie wir
erklären Sie sich oder wir erklären Sie
mir das habe ich seine Politik macht er
hat doch zwei hochqualifizierte
Staatssekretär an seiner Seite ein
Reichen und die Gold
geübt und routiniert und alte Hasen in
der Promotion von alternativen Energien
wenn er davon nichts versteht dann kann
er die doch fragen wie kommt so etwas in
der wahrscheinlich mit dir selber Frage
wie sie sich stellen das sind doch keine
Leute also nichts gegen Gemüsehändler
die bis gestern auf dem Wochenmarkt
Gemüse angeboten haben das sind alles
gebildete Menschen und das sind Menschen
die auch Berater haben die ganze
Institute unterhalten von Sie beraten
werden wie kommt das dass sie mir eine
so unglaublichen Treffsicherheit in so
ein riesen Fettnapf treten ich gebe
Ihnen auf Dauer verstehen sie stelle es
mal fest das sind gebildete Leute aber
sie haben das überall wo sie hinschauen
erinnern Sie sich noch an die Vorhersage
von Frau Merkel im Jahre 2020 wäre das
eine Million Elektroautos geben und
heute werden ähnlicher Vorhersagen
gemacht ich finde es auch unglaublich
dass ihr vorher sagen natürlich
Illusion ist genauso verbreitet worden
die
Illusion verbreitet wurde dass die
Impfung gegen kurvig immun macht
Frau Gaschke will die ganze Zeit ja ich
glaube man muss der Fairness halber ich
sehe es im Wesentlichen ähnlich wie sie
aber man muss der fairnesheimer einmal
sagen es werden jetzt nicht Heizung die
funktionieren rausgerissen und Leute
dann aus dem aus dem ist Klang ein
bisschen so nicht also aus dem nichts
gezwungen als ich eine neue Heizung zu
kaufen sind sondern wenn sie wenn sie
kaputt gehen dann sozusagen sollen sie
ab 24 doch schnell passieren
bestimmte Zeit abgelaufen sind also wir
können ja immer noch laufen
also es ist schrecklich aber es ist
nicht ganz so schrecklich und die zweite
Punkt ist glaube ich wirklich also wenn
es nicht handfeste ökonomische
Interessen sind weil irgendeine Lobby
sich gerade mit einer Sache so gut
durchgesetzt hat dass das jetzt alle
haben müssen das ist der Gedanke ich
weiß ähm
dann ist es glaube ja es ist überhaupt
Ideologie
etwas glauben und sozusagen die die
christlichen Religion sind ja völlig
offen auf dem Rücken jetzt gibt's den
Glauben
Sozialismus ist ja auch nicht mehr das
was er mal war und insofern die Leute
wollen das sieht man ja gerade bei den
Jungen darauf kommen wir vielleicht noch
also sozusagen die Leute wollen an was
glauben und das was mich irritiert ist
wir sind ja eine pluralistische
Gesellschaft eben kein Fünfjahresplan
eigentlich sondern Regierung kann
abgewählt werden es gibt andere
gesellschaftliche Kräfte es gibt die
Gewerkschaften es gibt die Unternehmen
selbst und auch da steht sozusagen jetzt
die Bekämpfung der der Klimakatastrophe
überall vor der Klammer vor allem
anderen also ich frage mich in der Tat
auch und hier ist eine offene Frage ich
weiß keine Antwort darauf wann ist das
passiert das ist Thema wichtig ist haben
wir seit ein paar Jahren ja gewusst aber
wann ist es passiert dass sozusagen
alles andere dem Untersatz und wir haben
heute den ganz gutes Beispiel genau
dafür mit der Unterordnung mitgebracht
und zwar von Herrn Hassbecker nee ich
will noch mal zu dem Thema diesen dieser
Heizungs- diesen Heizung was sagen wir
sind nämlich direkt betroffen wir haben
am Stadtrand hier und bei Berlin haben
wir ein Studio ein turnstudio in dem
Bearbeiten das ist ein altes Haus
teilweise gedämmt teilweise nicht gut
gedämmt also wie so ein was ich immer
vergrößert hat ja wie so eine umgebaute
Scheune und so also ein cooles Objekt
und so und da ist jetzt die Heizung
kaputt unsere Gasheizung aktuell kaputt
so
Wärmepumpe kommt für dieses Haus wird
mit einer großen Grundfläche definitiv
nicht in Frage jetzt was sollen wir nun
machen ja wir wissen selber also wir
werden wahrscheinlich dann doch noch mal
eine neue Gasheizung einbauen müssen
auch dieses Jahr und das ist doch
Irrsinn man muss doch da
Übergangsfristen und das nicht mit mit
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand das kann
doch nicht gehen das kann nicht
funktionieren für viele Leute nicht und
für uns auch nicht
einbauen
ab nächstes Jahr dürften sie es nicht
mehr verboten und ich meine das ist ja
auch alles etwas heuchlerisch also wenn
Sie zum Beispiel Zugang zu fahren Wärme
haben die Fernwärme in Deutschland ist
überwiegen Fossil betrieben aber wenn
Sie Zugang zum Fernwärmenetz haben
könnten wir nicht nee aber ich meine nur
wenn dann dürften Sie das also würden
sie einfach sich eine vereinbaranschluss
kriegen und dann ist alles okay aber da
sieht und dafür können sie ja nichts
keinen Zugang haben dürfen sie das nicht
haben was haben sie an technologischen
Möglichkeiten ich meine wir haben das
auch bei uns im Haus wir haben sogar mal
geprüft mit der Wärmepumpe noch vor
Jahren weil wir irgendwie dachten naja
gut vielleicht geht das ja zwei
Gutachter beide haben uns gesagt um
Gottes Willen lassen Sie die Hände davon
sie müssen ihr ganzes Haus umbauen sonst
heizt das Ding nicht sie haben nur
explodierende Stromkosten so und ab
nächstes Jahr alle die in die Situation
kommen Heizung alt Heizung kaputt was
sollen die denn machen also ich finde
das wirklich so unverantwortlich und
dann sich hinzustellen zu sagen das
bedroht doch niemanden ich meine das
sind solche irrenkosten wie sollen die
Leute das bezahlen also das ist ja
wirklich nicht nur der Einbau der
Heizung Politiker die wissen das doch es
ist nicht dass sie von ihren eigenen
Plänen sich selbst haben überraschen
können die wissen doch was es bedeutet
offenbar nicht interessiert oder wo
Politik
ändern ein Politiker kann im Notfall
auch ein Kredit aufnehmen der kriegt
immer ein Gerät und kann sich sein Haus
umbauen lassen und dann hat ein schönes
niedrig Energiehaus und dann kann er
auch eine Wärmepumpe drin haben aber was
macht in Rentnerehepaar die haben das
Häuschen endlich abbezahlt diese frohe
die wollten ihren Ruhestand genießen die
kriegen nirgendwo ein Kredit also selbst
wenn Sie Ihr Haus super dämmen wollten
weil sie sagen na gut vielleicht
rentiert sich irgendwann bei den Enkeln
die können das gar nicht also das ist
einfach nicht nicht von vorn bis hinten
durchdacht und dann kommt noch was dazu
ich meine das wird den Leuten ja auch
nicht gesagt die EU erweckt zurzeit
dieses Kältemittel zu verbieten was in
den Wärmepumpen ist das heißt im
notfalls klimaschädlich ist also im
schlimmsten Fall zwingen wir jetzt Leute
oder animieren sie dies Jahr sind sie
noch nicht gezwungen aber animieren sie
jetzt eine werbepumpe einzubauen im Haus
also die kann man ja draußen oder
drinnen aber wenn man sie drin einbaut
dann ist auf jeden Fall einfach
Kältemittel drin was möglicherweise in
wenigen Jahren von der EU verboten wird
dann müssen Sie die wieder rausreißen
müssen die anderen eine andere draußen
einbauen damit die mit einem anderen
Kältemittel funktioniert
die Ausnahmen ab 80 das muss ich sagen
das ist schon fast schon zynisch ja nach
dem Motto die haben eh nicht mehr so
lange das ist Geschmack 70-Jährige der
kriegt auch kein Kredit also
ja ich würde sagen anderes Thema bringt
sie ja noch viel mehr in Wallung und das
ist ja die Insel Rügen ja ja also ich
denke schon dass LNG terminals in diese
Umgebung nicht unbedingt passen ja das
ist eine schöne Insel die lebt vor allen
Dingen vom Tourismus die lebt von der
Landwirtschaft
Industrie an sich gibt es das kaum wenig
bis kaum und ähm
ich glaube wirklich dass das ich bin ja
schon froh dass diese dieser Standort
der ursprünglich angepeilt wurde vor
Selin dass das von Tisch ist ähm jetzt
geht es um Sassnitz genau gesagt um den
Hafen Industriehafen von Kran
und ähm es ist ein zwei schneidiges
Schwert also sagen wir mal das Geschrei
ist jetzt groß wir wollen die Umwelt
schützen das ist alles richtig und von
Meeresbiologen angefangen weil wie
gesagt Umwelt und Küstenschutz spielt
doch eine ganz große Rolle und
Naturschutz an sich auch
aber irgendwie irgendwoher muss das ja
kommen er muss sie das Gas muss ja
irgendwo rankommen das muss ja irgendwo
der erst ich meine wenn die Heizung
ausgehen im Winter weil das Gas alle ist
da ist das Geschrei wahrscheinlich noch
doppelt größer deswegen sollen wir nicht
mehr mit Gas heizen aber hier ist
natürlich dann die Sache also die das
billige Gas sehr Geschichte
dementsprechend wo soll die Regierung
das machen das ist eben die Frage ja ich
meine das will keiner vor seiner Tür
haben das ist schon richtig ja und
ehrlich gesagt ich weiß darauf auch ich
weiß da keine Lösung ja ich meine
bestehende Strukturen hätte man nutzen
können das hätte ich irgendwie schon
ganz klug gefunden aber das ist ja nur
nicht mehr möglich an in der aktuellen
Situation und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
ich vermute auch die machen das so oder
so und die da bin ich wieder bei der
Kommunikation wenn man die Leute
mitnehmen will dann muss man doch vorher
mit den reden ja man muss den das
erklären was man vorhat und warum und
wie rum was was ist noch für
Lösungsmöglichkeiten gibt dass man davon
die Bürger sind überzeugen können also
glauben Sie wirklich es liegt an der
Kommunikation bei Rügen weil ich meine
Rügen lebt auch vom Tourismus also hätte
man jetzt wirklich mit einer netten
Kommunikation übt sich ja immerhin
netter Kommunikation also genügend
kommunikative Videos dreht er ja glauben
Sie nicht das Problem wäre so oder so da
gewesen es ist immer da klar ich meine
Energieversorgung dieses bildet die
Grundlage für unser Leben für unseren
Wohlstand am Ende und wie gesagt es muss
irgendwo ankommen ja man und dann muss
man vielleicht auch manchmal sozusagen
ein bisschen dem Rat der auf dem Rat der
Experten hören
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt keine
vernünftige Lösung fragen wir die
Politikerin hier in der Runde nach der
Lösung ja also zunächst mal ich glaube
auch dass wir Gas brauchen also die Idee
dass wir jetzt nur noch Sonne und Wind
und damit können wir irgendwie unsere
Energiebedürfnisse erfüllen das ist
lächerlich also wir brauchen schon auch
dass es die sogenannte Grundlast also
wir brauchen Energieträger die dauerhaft
zur Verfügung stehen auch wenn der Wind
nicht weht und die Sonne nicht scheint
so Gas ist dadurch aus denkbar aber
ehrlich gesagt man da wird mir
vielleicht der Bruder jetzt wieder
sprechen aber ich meine da liegen Röhren
am ostseegrund die sind leicht zerstört
die kann man reparieren die zerstören
nicht das Meeres Wasser die machen keine
Industrie
Industrie in vor die vor die Rügen Küste
ich finde wenn wir gar nicht Stream
wieder öffnen reparieren reparieren und
mit mit Russland darüber verhandeln zu
welchem Preisen und ob wir das Gas
bekommen weil man muss ja wissen
kann das auch woanders verkaufen also es
ist nicht so das Russland geschädigt ist
wenn wir das gar nicht verkaufen wir
schädigen uns jetzt aktuell läuft es
darauf hinaus dass im Grunde die Türkei
zu Drehscheibe für den Verkauf von
russischen Gas auch nach Europa wird und
eine europäische Länder kaufen das Gas
also die sind doch völlig skrupellos
also muss ich sagen wenn wir damit
sowieso nichts ausrichten im Sinne
dessen dass wir Putin jetzt irgendwie
den Stinkefinger zeigen und diesen Krieg
beenden was ich auch Wünsche also ich
meine ich würde gerne alles dafür tun
dass dieser Krieg zu Ende geht aber ich
glaube nicht dass die Lösung darin
besteht dass wir jetzt diese wirklich
extrem Umwelt zerstörerischen Terminals
ich meine 12 solche Terminal sollen
entstehen 12 Stück und habe ich hat eine
Sondergenehmigung erteilt dafür dass die
ihren Dreck und zwar wirklich
ungefiltert ins Meerwasser ja aber das
ist wirklich keine das ist keine
verantwortungsvolle Politik und da sie
recht haben wir brauchen Gas also
sollten wir gucken ob es
umweltverträglichere Formen gibt Gas zu
kaufen und wahrscheinlich sogar
billigere Form bleiben einmal ja oder
ja was sie gerade erzählen Frau
Wagenknecht da trennen sich unsere Wege
wirklich den gleichen Vorschlag machen
ja Politiker indem sie Drogen
legalisieren wollen um den Schwarzmarkt
auszutrocknen und sie sagen wir müssen
Gas aus Russland beziehen also uns damit
arrangieren damit Indien und
Griechenland und die anderen Profiteure
des Schwarzhandels nicht mehr zum
zugekommen
eindeutig aber wissen Sie wenn Sie vom
Preis reden dürfen sie nicht nur den
Finanzberichten sie müssen auch in den
politischen und im moralischen Preis
berechnen und in dieser Situation auf
Handel und Kompromisse mit Russland zu
setzen ist entschuldige das Modewort
menschenverachtend dafür kapieren Leute
in der Ukraine aber beenden den Krieg
doch nicht dadurch dass wir das gar
nicht mehr kaufen also wir müssen viel
tun diesen Krieg zu beenden ich finde
auch dass Deutschland deine viel
aktivere Rolle spielen sollte aber nicht
damit dass wir hier einfach mal anderen
Ländern die Möglichkeit geben das
billige Gas zu kaufen und jetzt brauchen
wir verstehen Sie mich absichtlich
wissen sie es gibt Leute und es gab
Leute die sind absichtlich der NSDAP
beigetreten oder später der SED um
schlimmstes zu verhindern und wir wollen
jetzt zum Beispiel sie wollen ich nicht
Interessen und Geschäfte mit Russland
machen damit uns nicht der Arsch
abfriert und sie sagen auf den Krieg hat
es sowieso keinen Einfluss das wissen
wir nicht vielleicht doch wer hat es
doch ein langfristigen Einfluss das hat
sicher keinen Einfluss auf die kurze
Zeit aber sie wollen einen Status vorher
bei führen den wir schon mal hatten und
unter dem das Land inzwischen ziemlich
leidet nämlich der Abhängigkeit von
Russland ein abhängig will ich nicht
sein ich finde schon dass man eine
kleine Mengen einführen
will ich raus aus diesen Energieträgern
also wenn wir zum Beispiel tatsächlich
neue Technologien entwickeln ich habe
vorhin Fusionsreaktor und sowas erwähnt
da brauchen wir dieses dauert
Innovation kann manchmal schneller gehen
als man denkt wir sollten daran arbeiten
unabhängig zu werden aber ich finde das
andere bei diesem Moral die scheint mir
auch unehrlich weil gucken sich die
Deutschen Handelsbeziehungen an also wo
kaufen wir alles unsere Güter da sind
genügend Schurkenstaaten dabei da sind
Länder dabei die verbrecherische Kriege
führen da sind Länder dabei die ihre
Oppositionellen enthaupten da sind
Länder dabei die die für wirklich
übelste Dinge Verantwortung tragen
nicht mehr Russland sondern weniger
Saudi Arabien ja Sie können aber wo
kommt dann alles her was wir so
verwenden und wir haben übrigens
verkaufen auch noch viel in Russland ich
meine das stimmt ja auch nicht wir
kaufen zwar kein Gas mehr und kein Öl
mehr aber wir kaufen Nickel und wir
kaufen andere Vorprodukte die wir alle
brauchen und die Franzosen holen Ihr
Uran dort das angereicherte Uran damit
sie ihre Atomkraftwerke betreiben
also wenn alles zutiefst unehrlich ist
sagen sie einfach gar kein Handel mehr
Russland na ja das wäre sozusagen die
Maximalforderung aber ich finde auch
also man kann in dieser Situation das
nicht auf die Energie Frage reduzieren
sondern in dieser Situation keine Frage
des reinen Marktpreises sondern eine
Frage des des moralischen Preises und
den bin ich nicht bereit zu bezahlen an
ein Land das in der Ukraine die Leute
abschlachtet und und ihnen das Land und
ihre Zukunft wegnehmen will
Leute abschlachtet das ist auch ganz
grauenhaft dann ist bin ich sehr bei der
Außenministerin die ja viel gescheuten
wird für ihre sozusagen wertebasierte
Außenpolitik die versucht den Begriff
auszuweiten aber vielleicht ich weiß
nicht wollen wir das jetzt mit der
Ukraine weiter vertiefen sonst würde ich
doch noch
schlimmer ist aber einige Liegen von
unserer Haustür und einige liegen weit
weg und da geht meine Sorge er den
Nachbarn ich würde sagen wir sprechen ja
auch noch über die aus einem anderen
schlimm energiepolitischen Problemen
gerne noch mal kommen das auch aber sehr
damit zu tun hat also wenn man jetzt die
russlandfrage wiederum noch nicht
beantworten kann an dieser Stelle es ist
ja ein bisschen das Problem dass also
viele also auch der schönen Technologien
also zum Beispiel Wind was uns ja immer
sehr sozusagen nahe gebracht worden ist
an landschaftlich schön Orden
stattfindet also die Nordseeküste in
Schleswig-Holstein sieht auch
katastrophal aus inzwischen das sind
Industrielandschaften das hat also mit
Land der Horizonte oder wie sie sich
früher meiner nichts mehr
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht hat
sich damals für die Leute ziemlich
gelohnt glaube ich also es war kein
Zusatzgeschäft für die für die
sogenannten Windmüller was ich sagen
will ist inzwischen ist es aber ganz
schwierig sie kriegen also mit guten
Gründen ich verstehe das ja warum sie
kriegen da die Terminals nicht Terminals
nicht in sie kriegen fast keine neuen
Wind Energieanlagen mehr hin sie kriegen
keine Stromtrassen hin weil es sofort
Initiativen dagegen gibt und das ist
natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein
Problem also da hat er wahrscheinlich
nicht irgendwo muss es her aber das
heißt es ist es gibt ein
Spannungsverhältnis zwischen der
Produktion von Energie und der Schönheit
von meiner Mama auch ein Problem wenn
ich sie frage wie viel Strom hat das
denn gebracht und dann sagen Sie was
übrigens bei vielen so ist der das
müsste mal gucken und ich glaube ist das
nicht ein Problem auch in der Debatte
das ganz oft ja auch Initiativen dagegen
gegründet werden weil auch das was
rauskommen würde an Strom überhaupt
nicht so viel ist ich weiß nicht
vielleicht wir jetzt sind bei den
erneuerbaren Energien also es ist schon
schon besser geworden in Deutschland
deutlich nicht
mal sozusagen
im letzten Jahr gehabt aber das linke
das liegt am Wetter auch manchmal ganz
so es kann man ja sein wo die Sonne
weniger scheint der Wind weniger weht
dann sind wir gleich wieder deutlich
drüber alleine in den fossilen also das
wechselt eben und was ich eben auch
nicht verstehe zu sagen oder wo ich
finde da macht man den Leuten was vor
also wenn wir jetzt so tun wie habe ich
wir müssen nur noch viel mehr Windräder
hinstellen und dann haben wir irgendwann
100% erneuerbare Energien nein das
stimmt nicht wir haben ja teilweise
jetzt schon Tage viele sogar im Jahr da
werden die Anlagen mit Erneuerbaren vom
Netz genommen weil der Wind zu sehr wird
das heißt da haben wir viel zu viel
schon aber wenn der Wind nicht weht dann
nützen die zusätzlichen Anlagen nichts
weil also viele Anlagen produzieren dann
auch nicht negativen Preisen an unserer
Nachbarn verlieren negative Preise auch
eine wunderbare
gleich viel Wind und bei der Sonne ist
es auch so ich meine ich verstehe wenn
z.B in China ein bestimmten Breiten wo
sehr viel Sonne Energie sehr viel Sonne
scheint immer wieder und ständig und
lange Tage und was weiß ich ja der lohnt
sich Solar aber in Deutschland also ich
etwas mit den Dächern ganz sinnvoll dass
man das auch begünstigt aber wir sind
nun mal ein Land wo auch sehr oft der
himmelwolken verhangen ist und im Winter
wo wir mehr Energie brauchen und schon
gar erst recht wenn wir noch mehr mit
Energie mit Strom heizen sollen im
Winter ist diese der Solarstrom
natürlich fällt der fast vollständig aus
in unseren Breiten das muss man einfach
wissen und deswegen ist das
Augenwischerei zu sagen wir haben jetzt
46% erneuerbare und wenn wir ganz viel
zubauen haben wir 100%, nein wäre
natürlich eine Lösung und aber da haben
wir das gleiche Problem das möchte halt
niemand ein Endlager in seinem Wahlkreis
haben wir Fragen hier einmal äh
Herzberger die thesia das Thema auch
mitgebracht hat was würde denn jetzt
passiert z.B mit ihrem Haus auf Rügen
wenn die Eltern jetzt und so weiter wenn
das dann Altstadt findet wäre da nicht
das Haus auch irgendwann weniger wert
die Insel ist relativ groß also das muss
man wissen also wir sind nicht direkt
davon betroffen sind oft auf dem anderen
Ende der Insel sozusagen im Nordwesten
und das ganze findet im soll im Südosten
stattfinden und
natürlich wird es für die entsprechenden
Betroffenen Seebäder und da gibt es
heißt bin's Prora das sind alles große
Strandabschnitte schöne
seebädererholungsorte dass die Bären
schon irgendwie betroffen und man sieht
das dann auch natürlich ne aber diesen
Hafen sieht man eh jetzt auch schon ne
der der noch übrig ist und es kann sein
dass da natürlich auch sozusagen der
Tourismus dann wegbricht beispielsweise
oder weniger gleich von wegbrechen reden
aber es wird natürlich vielleicht den
ein oder anderen geben der da vielleicht
nicht mehr hin will oder so ne weil ihm
das stört oder so
dann können Sie einfach mehr Touristen
aus China ist doch auch prima oder ich
weiß nicht doch
Wind jede Menge dort auch im Winter also
insofern ich habe da überhaupt nicht
gegen also und da gibt's auch so eine
offshore Parks ne in diesen aber so weit
vor die Küste gebaut dass man sie von
Strand aus gar nicht mehr sehen kann
über die Touristen aus China die lassen
wir jetzt mal ausfallen gehen in eine
ganz kurze Werbepause sondern direkt
wieder zurück mit dem Thema von Herrn
Bruder
[Musik]
wir haben viel zu besprechen heute Abend
wie steht's um unser Land
damit herzlich willkommen bei Viertel
nach Hering frei
und war doch allen klar ist wirklich zu
einfach diesen Krieg begonnen aber wir
entscheiden doch was wir machen
eigentlich fordern sie die Aufarbeitung
und den Rücktritt von Karl Lauterbach
lieber umgekehrt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen als freiheitsliebender Mensch
würde ich sagen das muss jedem erlaubt
sein kein Mensch zwischen Bremer und
Bruder
Winterstart Geld verschenkt muss das ja
irgendwo anders herbekommen dass das
wird das Problem nicht ändern das ist
unser Mittel war glaube ich auch kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen dass das so
durch geht und das ist leider Gottes
auch ein Punkt mit dem wir reden sollten
damit der Film nach acht Entzug nicht zu
groß wird definitiv noch einmal ein
Scheiß
[Musik]
ganz Deutschland ist im Griff der
klimakleber so erscheint es und das
Internet ist voll von Videos wie diesem
ich glaube
alles passiert trotzdem nichts
bei der Regierung hat keinen Plan
Frau Gaschke wecken diese Interview
diese Videos Interviews sind ja nicht
Mitgefühl in ihnen
ein bisschen Mitgefühl und ein bisschen
die Frage ist das nicht Satire und ein
bisschen das Gefühl also brauchen die
mal ein paar um die Ohren also es ist
tatsächlich nein sehr gegen körperliche
Zustimmung
nein es ist natürlich es ist ja das gute
Recht junger Leute ideologisch zu sein
und fanatisch zu sein und sich in die
Ideen rein zu steigern und so weiter das
tun sie wahrscheinlich
wirklich das ist keine Satire weil ein
Mädchen Pauline filmt ja und ihre Angst
ja vor dem klimawand Angst das haben wir
in Corona gelernt ist auch ein ideales
Erpressungsmittel also mit seiner
eigenen Angst kann man andere Leute toll
unter Druck setzen weil man darf nicht
dagegen sagen das wäre fies schon was
ich jetzt sage ist unheimlich fies weil
ich das nicht ernst nehme ich ich stehe
also ich kann das nicht beurteilen wie
viel Angst sie tatsächlich persönlich
hat ich finde nur nicht dass sie und
andere das Recht haben alle anderen ihre
Angst zu terrorisieren sondern wir sind
hier immer noch ein demokratischer Staat
wenn man der Meinung ist es muss viel
schneller viel mehr passieren dann muss
man dafür werben dann muss man dafür
Leute auf seine Seite ziehen die
mitmachen wollen da muss man dafür in
Parteien gehen oder selber Parteien
Gründen und um Mehrheiten werben denn
ich meine diese Klimabewegung muss ich
doch auch selbst ernst nehmen also die
die die die wissen doch dass es wenn es
so ist wie sie sagen und es so schnell
gehen muss und so doll dass sie viele
Leute zum Mitmachen bewegen müssen im
Moment stoßen sie alle Leute ab und und
Leute wir alle merken in uns dass wir so
irgendwie zu viel drakonischeren Strafen
neigen und und und also irgendwie das
Gefühl haben so kann das Kinder so kann
das wirklich nicht weitergehen im Dialog
wenn sie jetzt im Dialog mit Pauline
werden aus dem Video was würden Sie Ihr
denn entgegnen
naja ehrlich gesagt mir fällt das auch
ein bisschen schwer also das ernst zu
nehmen also ich finde das ist
pathologisch also das ist wirklich
pathologisch natürlich ist der
Klimawandel etwas was man wo man etwas
dagegen tun muss aber so zu tun als
würde jetzt irgendwie also erstmal kann
Deutschland das nicht alleine das heißt
nicht soll kein Alibi sein nicht zu
machen aber so zu tun als würden wir
also zum Beispiel wenn wir unsere ganze
Industrie killen klar sind wir dann
vorbildlich in unseren Klimazielen die
Industrie produziert nur woanders und
meistens dreckiger also
suchen ich will da noch ganz viel von
ihnen heute hören geben wir aber einmal
zuhören oder der seine These auch zu dem
Thema heute mitgebracht hat und
vielleicht auch eine Lösung hat wie man
mit Pauline und den anderen umgeht ja
ich würde Paulinen öffentlichen
Therapeuten empfehlen vorausgesetzt es
ist wirklich authentisch und nicht aus
ein Clip aus der heute show was da
wunderbar reinpassen würde aber es tut
mir leid die machen solche Witze aber
nicht
also es ist immer peinlich wenn lange
oder alte Frauen über junge Menschen
lästern und ich habe ja auch einen
ordentlichen
alte Männer am Anfang ich habe auch ein
ordentlichen demonstrationshintergrund
aber uns haben damals die
Demonstrationen noch Spaß gemacht das
sind alles kranke Menschen deswegen
haben sie vollkommen Recht entschuldigen
Sie dass ich einen zustimme das ist
pathologische Phänomen sind das sind
paranoika und Hysteriker in einer
paranoiden und hysterischen Gesellschaft
und deswegen fliegen diesen Leuten auch
viele Herzen zu und ein Argument wenn
sie so machen merke ich soll aufhören
aber jetzt mache ich weiter
ja ich höre immer wieder ich höre immer
wieder in Debatten ja das mag ja falsch
sein aber es ist für einen guten Zweck
der seinen absolut totalitäres Argument
dass man etwas macht das nicht geht weil
der Zweck so gut ist damit sind bis
jetzt alle Diktaturen zum Zuge gekommen
alle Diktaturen
bieten nur das Gute laden und das ist
hier die große Lüge ich meine das ein
junge Menschen die furchtbar leiden weil
glaube ich seit Wörter wollen junge
Menschen auch leiden aber sie haben
keinen richtigen Anlass mehr dazu sie
sind wohlbehindert aufgewachsen sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch gut erzogen haben
ordentliche akademische Abschlüsse oder
was auch immer und es geht sogar so weit
dass ich von einer jungen Frau gelesen
habe in Regensburg oder Würzburg also
irgendwo aus der bayerischen Provinz die
hat gesagt er hat sich sterilisieren
lassen und keine Kinder zu bekommen weil
in dieser Welt kann man keine Kinder
reinsetzen abgesehen davon
noch andere Mittel gibt und keine Kinder
haben das früher gemacht und Feministen
zu sein ja genau genau aber das wissen
Sie das haut alles nicht hin die
gehörlose Halle auf die Couch aber die
Aktivisten sagen eigentlich weil Kinder
die größte Klima Sünde sind ja das kann
schon so sein dass nächste Mal in der
paar Wochen haben sie gesagt Haustiere
sind die größte Klima Sünde ich habe
schon einen Hund in Sicherheit gebracht
wirklich bevor sie ihn zu einer Fraktion
Nutzung der Grünen einladen nein schauen
Sie wer erleben eigentlich jetzt eine
Katastrophe der Staat hat jetzt Manifest
versagt es sind Straftatbestände denen
wir es zu tun haben da ist natürlich
Nötigung Eingriff in den Straßenverkehr
und ich finde übrigens auch Geiselnahme
Freiheitsberaubung dann tausende von
Leuten in den Autos sitzen egal wo die
hin wollten das heißt immer die Mutter
mit Kind zum Arzt egal ich unterwegs zum
Kaffee genauso wichtig denn tausende von
Leuten im Auto sitzen ist das
Geiselnahme und dann heute ist das erste
Urteil mit der nicht bewerten auf Strafe
erlassen worden in Berlin vier Monate
nein viel zu wenig so aber wir wollen
Sie denn Herr Bruder
nein schauen Sie ich wollte nur eins
sagen und dann können Sie wieder
entspannen
der Staat ist ein enteierter Bulle und
er lässt sich das alles bieten und ich
sehe wie die armen Polizisten nicht nur
diese Leute wegtragen müssen sondern die
liebevoll sie die Hände loslösen müssen
mit Olivenöl und anderen wertvollen
Rohstoff wo er sieht jetzt nicht immer
so liebevoll aus also dass der der die
Polizisten streicheln nicht noch die
Aktivierung
das finde ich aber wir haben es eine
Staatsversammlung zu tun und derweil
derweil lachen alle und freuen sich und
dieser Kids geben ihre Pressekonferenzen
in Kirchen das ginge müsste man
sozusagen im Prinzip die Bühne anziehen
das heißt keine Presse mehr vor Ort
keine Kameras keine Polizisten das geht
nur nicht das wird nicht aber dann wäre
das ganz schnell erledigt weil es keiner
mitkriegt ja was kann ich glaube das
wirklich schlimmer an diesen Aktionen
ist ja dass sie genau das gegenteilige
das den gegenteiligen Effekt haben den
sie sich offenbar versprechen die Leute
werden die kriegen eine blasse Wut also
ich meine ich verstehe das ich muss
Arbeit oder ich muss irgendwo hin wo ich
pünktlich sein muss und dann oder ich
persönlich muss zum Beispiel zum
Flughafen manchmal und muss den Flug
kriegen so und wenn man dann fliegen
noch um Gottes Willen ja das Saarland
ist schon ein Stückchen weg da kommt man
zumindest mit dieser Bahn die dann ewig
verspätet hat nicht hin also wie gesagt
irgendwo muss man hin man ist in seinem
Auto unterwegs und plötzlich kompletter
Stau Klima Kleber so was ist der Effekt
ja die Leute haben eine stinke Wut auf
diese auf die junge Leute und damit
natürlich auch auf das ganze Klima
Problem also wenn man es wirklich
schaffen will dass der Begriff
Klimaschutz oder Klimawandel nur noch zu
einem anti-begriff wird wo die Leute
fragen Platz dann muss man es genauso
machen und ich finde auch ist unredlich
ich meine was hat der normale Autofahrer
mit dem Klimawandel zu tun ich meine die
können sich das Auto ja aber selbst ja
vielleicht auch nicht richtig ausgebaut
ist oder weil er eben ja natürlich seine
Mobilität haben will also ich finde ich
meine die können sich vor Habicht
Ministerium ankleben den ganzen Tag habe
nichts dagegen sie können denjenigen die
sie verantwortlich machen da können sie
ihre Aktion machen alles gut aber dass
sie ganz normale Bürger die wirklich
überhaupt keine Verantwortung dafür
tragen die aber die Leidtragenden sind
in dieser Weise schädigen und wütend
machen und ich meine auch ein
Arbeitgeber sagt ja nicht wenn man dann
viel zu spät kommt ja da war der Klima
da waren die klimakleber ne dann sagt
der Arbeitgeber trotzdem dahin so anders
fahren müssen also man kriegt ja Ärger
man hat immer Schwierigkeiten dadurch
und die Leute die das erleben müssen ja
das soll nicht so dass die dann so toll
jetzt müssen wir noch mehr für die für
die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels tun ich
will von diesem Thema nichts mehr hören
ich bin müde viel viel Einigkeit hier am
Tisch heute zu den Klima kleben jetzt
haben wir aber anstatt Pauline noch
Richard David Precht der stört nämlich
susanne Gaschke
Unfall dass diese Frau Außenministerin
geworden ist ja also ich nehme an dass
die hätte noch normal am unter normalen
Bedingungen im Auswärtigen Amt nicht
mein Praktikum gekriegt dass jemand mit
so diesem moralischen Inbrunst einer
Klassensprecherin einer Weltmacht einer
Kulturnation versucht zu erklären was
westliche Werte sind sie als systemische
Rivalen definiert und quasi ein
eskalationsszenario an die Wand malt
eine Werte geleitete Außenpolitik die
Wirklichkeit eine konfrontations
geleitet Aussenpolitik ist
warum ja wir sind da eigentlich zwei
Sachen dran aufgefallen also das erste
war natürlich wirklich diese
unglaubliche Verachtung mit der dieser
Mann über die amtierende Außenministerin
spricht und da dachte ich das ist doch
eben so also völlig Diesseits noch all
dieser Wolken
Regeln wie wir jetzt nicht mehr sprechen
dürfen und wen wer wie nicht
diskriminieren dürfen und wenn wir
wohnen das ist so ganz solide
Frauenfeindlichkeit und und Herablassung
also von Typen von Typen immer noch gibt
die sich vermutlich selbst ja für
aufgeklärt halten ich nehme an das hat
recht dass das vermutlich tut so also
das fand ich schon ganz schön ganz schön
bemerkenswert also es ist Element von
von Herablassung darin und das zweite
ist natürlich ein allgemeinerer Punkt
und den finde ich schon sehr
besorgniserregend nicht nur im Bezug auf
China sondern eben auch im Bezug auf
Russland und den Ukraine Krieg dieses
also zu sagen also geleitet der
Außenpolitik es ist Einmischung wir
dürfen sozusagen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen eben gerade
Ländern wie China nicht vorhalten ich
würde sagen die Hongkong Chinesen oder
die Menschen in Tai waren die machen
sich schon ganz fundamentale Gedanken um
ihre Menschenrechte oder die Uiguren
oder überhaupt politische Opposition
dort genauso in Russland selbst ist ja
die die Opposition praktisch praktischen
mundtot gemacht also wer wer wer da
anderer Meinung ist als Putin ist im
Gefängnis oder im Ausland und das alles
kommt dann so daher also auch Männer die
sehr viel mehr geschätzt habe als recht
also zum Helmut Schmidt haben ist ein
bisschen ähnlich immer vertreten also
wir sollen uns doch hier auf unsere
wirtschaftlichen Dinge kümmern und nicht
einmischen irgendwie fremdkulturell dann
in die chinesische Kultur und dann sind
doch alle wirtschaftlich glücklich ich
finde dass man das also in einer derart
vernetzten Welt nicht mehr machen kann
dass man überlegen muss mit wem man
Geschäfte macht und welche Art von
Geschäften dass wir auch bei China eben
sehr viel vorsichtiger sein müssen als
letztes Jahr lang waren und viel
vorsichtiger als gegenüber Russland wo
wir uns ja also willentlich und und und
ohne also ohne fundamentale not in eine
gasabhängigkeit zum Beispiel gegeben
haben als man längst wusste wie die in
der Ukraine reagieren
also was was agieren was sie da tun also
nach 2014 hat also jeder
Wirtschaftsminister noch mitgewirkt an
der Übergabe der Gasspeicher an an an
Gazprom an den verkaufen aber das
bedeutet Sie haben eine andere Meinung
ja recht eine Unterhaltung aber finden
Sie den Landes hätte eingreifen müssen
also wie weit geht ihre Kritik da da
Verbrechen das nicht sagen wunderbar
also deswegen sitzen wir hier und oder
deswegen hauen wir uns ja darüber das
ist ja das Schöne an eine Demokratie da
kommt niemand für ins Gefängnis
Geld vielleicht viel Gegenwind auf
Twitter aber das kann man ja wenn man
sich in diese Kanäle begibt dann muss
man damit auch leben was ich nicht mag
ist eine Haltung die in Deutschland dann
doch immer mal wieder rauskommt und
vielleicht noch mehr als in Bezug auf
China im Bezug auf die Ukraine die sagt
lasst uns damit irgendwie in Ruhe also
dann wird auch die Angst
instrumentalisiert die Leute haben dann
Angst vorm Atomkrieg oder für
irgendwelchen schrecklichen Dingen die
sind ja auch alle schrecklich vor Putin
muss man auch Angst haben ganz richtig
Angst zu haben aber die Größe die
größeren Grund für Angst den haben nun
wirklich gerade die Ukraine drin und
Ukraine die da vergewaltigt ermordet
deren Kinder verschleppt und deren Land
kaputt gemacht wird und dieses diese
Mentalität hier dann zu sagen lasst mich
damit lieber in Ruhe also macht lieber
keine rechts ist eigentlich der
auffänger ja das große Ganze
typische Haltung ist also er macht damit
ja auch krass also oder Kasse er macht
damit Einschaltquoten
also ich muss ehrlich sagen mir hat er
aus dem Herzen gesprochen ich finde
eine völlig überforderte Außenministerin
ist also dass sie am Abend nicht
gewachsen ist und ich glaube nicht dass
in Deutschland gut vertritt weil ich
meine ich bin auch der Meinung dass wir
bei China genau hingucken müssen welche
Art Wirtschaftsbeziehungen wir machen
weil wir natürlich ein Rivalen haben der
bisher sehr geschickt ist verstanden hat
unsere Technologien zu holen sie im
eigenen Land einzusetzen und uns damit
am Ende Konkurrenz zu machen aber doch
nein ich meine nur ich habe ihr ja
zugestimmt was aus dem
Wirtschaftspolitik angeht aber ich finde
auf diese plumpe Art wie Frau bärburg
das macht kommen wir überhaupt nicht
weiter und sie ist auch unehrlich ich
meine diese Werte basierte Außenpolitik
der ganze globale südenacht sich tot
über die Werte basierte Außenpolitik des
Westens weil ich meine die diese Werte
haben eingeschlossen dass viele Kriege
geführt wurden auch Deutschland übrigens
hat ja eine sehr ungute Geschichte jetzt
zum weit zurückliegen aber trotzdem in
China ich meine wir haben dort gewütet
also dass der Boxeraufstand wieder
geschlagen wurde das waren grauenvolle
Verbrechen jetzt kommt die deutsche
Außenministerin und spielt sich da als
normal
die Chinesen haben es nicht vergessen
also ich glaube man sollte das zumindest
im Hinterkopf behalten
wie spricht man elegant mit einem
Diktator über Menschenrechte
was heißt elegant also weil sie sagten
es war plump oder es war es war ungelenk
also wie wie tut man unsere Haltung
deutlich machen aber diese Haltung also
es ist eine Doppelmoral weil wir sie
einfach bei einigen Ländern raushängen
lassen und bei anderen tun nichts
verschweigen wenn die einen was machen
finden wir das ganz schlimm dann gehen
wir zu dem nächsten Diktator habe ich
gleich ein paar Tage Frau merburg machen
großen glücklingen weil wir hoffen dass
wir dann Gas aus Katar bekommen so das
ist doch also das ist doch alles
Heuchelei und das finde ich ist das
Problem dieser sogenannten
wertebasierten Außenpolitik man hat
selber immer wieder während der
gebrochen man hat immer wieder
Völkerrecht aufgenommen
ist sie sitzen eine Partei der Erben der
SPD
lange Vergangenheit ich bitte Sie
Boxeraufstand war glaube ich 1900 wenn
ich mir nicht täusche das was ich meine
hat hier vor 30 Jahren stattgefunden
ich durfte nicht studieren
was weiß ich nicht war vielleicht habe
vielleicht also ja aber wir reden
trotzdem Unsinn ja wir mögen wissen sie
leiden veredelt die Menschen nicht das
kann eine viel Leiden trotzdem doof
bleiben das gibt es ja das habe ich aber
nicht ein Abrede gestellt trotzdem würde
ich finde auch nicht dass wir die
DDR-Geschichte jetzt leugnen oder oder
auch das was
Unrecht statt bezeichnet es hat eine DDR
grobes Unrecht gegeben überhaupt keine
Frage aber ich glaube das ist einfach
eine andere das ist jetzt eine Debatte
die uns weiterführt dazu betrachten weil
ich habe in der DDR Schwierigkeiten
gehabt ich gehör nicht zu denen die von
der DDR profitiert haben ich wusste
nicht studieren ich hatte immer wieder
Probleme und ich habe am Ende überhaupt
nur einfach den schlechten Satz dass
beim Unrecht statt
verstehen ja ich finde was gegen Werbung
spricht ist einfach dass sie nicht nicht
das diplomatische Fingerspitzengefühl
hat was sie braucht sie sie führt bei
vielen Ländern und ich meine wir merken
das doch bei dir Sanktionspolitik warum
machen die meisten Länder des globalen
Südens bei den Sanktionen nicht mit weil
sie sagen am besten ist unehrlich weil
sie sagte sind ehrlich
und die anderen Diktatoren der Gegend
also zumindest
größte Teil der Weltbevölkerung
das sind total übelste Diktaturen die
plötzlich die Moralen Decken
gleichzeitig mit ihnen sozusagen wir
wollen jetzt unsere Außenpolitik aus dem
Wirtschaftspolitik nur noch auf den
westlichen
Kernländer oder ich meine selbst bei der
Ukraine wer guckt denn da genau hin was
da im Vorfeld des Krieges schon in
Fragen Menschenrechten schief gelaufen
ist ich meine das ist ein Land da wurden
Fernsehsender verboten da wurden auch
ehrlich
ein freiheitliches aber eben gesagt sie
soll nicht von für über 20 Jahren
sprechen und bei der Ukraine ist ja auch
viel passiert in den letzten Jahren also
wir reden ja jetzt schon wir müssen ja
schon sagen
transformationsgesellschaft nach dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion also die
die hatten alle ihren Weg zu gehen und
Demokratie dass das dauert natürlich
auch ein bisschen ja gut aber sie sie
sind eben grob das heißt sie sind
endlich frei und sie verehren zum
Beispiel Leute wie man Lehrer der war
gekommen
ist
können sie doch nicht gut halten
weniger gutheiße ich dass sie den
Massenmord in die Russen begehen
verknüpfen historisch und faktisch mit
der Korruption den der Ukraine
beherrscht hat wenn es doch doch
verurteilen
nein sie haben selber gesagt ich muss da
nichts hinlegen
geht müssen wir als erstes
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Bomben weil Frau
Schwesig extrem korrupt Verhalten hat
aber sowieso nicht dass mein korrupte
Länder mit Bomben
also ich meine wie gesagt ich finde
diesen Krieg ein Verbrechen ich finde
nur die Einäugigkeit dann so zu tun als
er in der Ukraine alles in Ordnung
und und es ist eine junge dynamische
sozusagen Gesellschaft
am besten drängte und wirklich nur so
leben wollte gerne so ungefähr frei und
ähnlich wie wir das hier tun und die
Russen Bomben die zurück ins Mittelalter
und die machen ihn jede Perspektive
kaputt dafür gibt's
auch weil sie immer immer über seinen
peinliche Veranstaltungen neulich in
Berlin haben schon selbst gemacht
natürlich war ich da mehr hat ein sehr
gut gefallen wie sie Frau warte das
Mikrofon umdrehen mussten weil sind das
falsche Ende gesprochen hat
das ist jetzt wirklich nicht irgendwie
irgendwo passiert
wir bleiben jetzt einmal bei der
Sachlichkeit und dann stelle ich mal
eine Frage nachdem ja Frau Wagenknecht
die Fragen beantwortet hat wie man diese
Position haben kann ist natürlich jetzt
die die Frage an sehr Bruder wie würden
Sie denn zu einem Ende des Krieges
kommen also was ist ihre Lösung wie bei
dort sterben ja viele Soldaten also
sogar Ukraine einfach russischer Seite
wie würden sie zwar am Ende kommen
wirklich das wüsste hätte ich längst
darüber geschrieben und es ist nicht
meine Aufgabe mir darüber Gedanken zu
machen wie der Krieg beendet werden
könnte wir haben 16 Landtage für ein
Bundestag bundesweit eine untergegangen
Organisation Parteien Stiftungen Partei
Nano Organisationen werden in Europa hat
den Europäischen Rat wir haben die
UNESCO warum soll ich es wissen ich weiß
nur eins dass ein Krieg diese Art ich
bin auch kein Pazifist und Kriege müssen
ab und zugeführt werden wenn die
Alliierten den Krieg gegen Nazis nicht
geführt hätten setzen wir nicht hier ich
zumindest nicht so aber in dem Falle
kann man die Fragen wie würden sie den
Krieg lösen natürlich kann man sagen
wenn der Westen auch für die Ukraine zu
bewaffnen ist schnell vorbei wenn man
dem Opfer zur schnell nachgeben dann
hört die Aggression mal auf aber das
kann nicht die Lösung sein nein ich
denke es muss eine viel stärkeren
Boykott gegenüber Russland geben
wirtschaftliche politische Maßnahmen
gestern war da immer so eine Sitzung in
New York war das nicht der
Sicherheitsrat der gestern gezeigt hat
irgendwas ähnliches wer war der
Vorsitzender der russische Außenminister
eine schlimmere moralische Demütigung
für den Westen kann es nicht geben und
da und was was die Russen jetzt machen
ist genau das genau das ist
intervenieren sie nicht gleich dass die
Nazis gemacht haben sie erklären sich zu
opfern für die Nazis waren die Polen und
die Juden die Opfer die eine ab
Deutschland angreifen wollten und sie
mussten
und die Ukraine macht das genauso und
Pudding ist dann schon Sie bitte putin
ist sowas wie Hitler ohne den Holocaust
und das macht die nicht weniger schlimm
und nicht weniger das ist
ich würde sagen das können wir jetzt
nicht noch mal weiter debattieren aber
wir kommen vielleicht in gleicher
Konstellation noch mal zusammen
debattieren Sie bitte auch zu Hause und
wir sind morgen abend wieder da tschüss
schönen Abend noch
[Musik]